economic freedom peaked about seven or
eight years ago in the US and has been
dropping since then hi I'm Matt Welch
for recent TV and I'm joined today by
Jim Roberts of the Heritage Foundation
who is the co-author of the 2012 index
of economic freedom which is as it
sounds like thanks for joining us Jim I
was wondering if you could just give us
a little background when did heritage
start putting out these indices of
economic freedom what are they trying to
do how are they different than other
things out there it the first edition
was in 1995 and the idea was
conservatives felt that the American
public and really the world at large
didn't have a good grasp what were the
fundamentals that underlie the great
prosperity we've enjoyed in the United
States and so to remind people and to
advocate for those policies limited
government low taxes strong rule of law
light regulation and open markets of
heritage sort of the index 2012 2011
2010 have been kind of bad years in the
developed West have they been bad years
for the world in terms of economic
freedom they haven't been great although
we had a little bit of an uptick last
year this year again it's gone down for
the world there are some bright spots in
sub-saharan Africa and Asia but bad news
for America is that for the third year
in a row there's been a precipitous drop
in economic freedom in the United States
and really economic freedom peaked about
seven or eight years ago in the US and
has been dropping since then what are
you measuring in the United States that
is dropping government spending score
has just gone through the roof as you
can imagine the Keynesian stimulus which
has failed but has left us heavily
indebted this administration and even
the prior one spending too much money
and not getting enough for a result
taking money out of the economy that
could be better used for private sector
investment and too much regulation and
it's strangling business it's making
business overly cautious people don't
know what to do especially with
Obamacare coming on the horizon so these
are been the main things but also
property rights where they had the abuse
of the of the rule of law in the United
States with the takeover of General
Motors and Chrysler for example the two
big
bank bailouts so these all counted
against the United States score and it
has dropped everybody wants to know what
what about China people fear China
people look down on China or whatever
how is china doing in terms of economic
freedom and how does that relate to
their own economic growth if at all well
they're sure not doing is nearly as well
as Hong Kong which has been number one
for the last 18 years and meanwhile the
mainland PRC is stuck below the middle
of the of the club the track so China as
well as they're doing think how much
better they could be doing if they
adopted these these principles if they
open up their political sector as they
have their economy if they had stronger
property rights and a strong rule of law
and a genuine open markets and didn't
play games with currency how much better
could they be doing quite a bit you're a
background is in property rights you
worked for the State Department for a
quarter century in order to put it that
way I tell us a little bit about China
and property rights do they have any
further for starters you know they do in
practice but not in law and that's the
problem if you have major investors
they're going to want to see not only
property rights enshrined in law but
actually a track record of the
government you know responsibly handling
that of courts that you don't have to
buy off judges protecting those property
rights that china is going to take time
to do that but they've got to start and
they haven't yet I talked a little bit
about to Western Europe which you've
dealt with in your professional career
over the years on some levels they have
great economic freedom compared to other
places but they're also on the verge of
a eurozone crisis or in the middle of it
really what does your research tell you
about what's happening right now and
what the trend lines are well clearly
the euro has failed the euro experiment
which was probably doomed from the start
although it was an attempt really to
keep the French and the Germans from
going to war against each other at least
that's the story line to coal and meet
Iran agreed 20 years ago but it hasn't
worked out the southern Europeans have
been kind of Free Riders for as long as
the party went on but now the party's
over and they're going to have to figure
a way to back out of the euro and even
countries like Sweden famous for
you know socialist governments are
figuring this out and trying to make
changes up recently sent a team to Chile
to figure out how chilly privatized
their social security system for example
so and Denmark has also been much more
flexible and they have done better in
our index as a result you've had some
experience in Eastern Europe not
necessarily in 2011 but like take from
1995 when you guys started doing this
what's the overall picture look like are
things still improving there or they
starting to hit roadblocks they've
improved certainly the countries of the
Czech Republic Slovakia Poland they have
done very well and Slovenia but the rest
of the former Yugoslavia maybe Croatia
has done okay there's still too much
corruption in Bulgaria and Romania they
were led into the European Union I think
probably a little early but in also in
line with their NATO membership so there
were political considerations at work
there there's still a lot to do there
the Serbs are still too much kind of
have the Russian kind of mentality in
terms of the control and the lack of
trust in the market so there's some work
to do but there's been some progress and
give us a nice story from sub-saharan
Africa which were not used to hearing
nice stories from necessarily over the
last 20 years well mauritius actually
which if you could count that i was out
in the ocean but they've now dropped it
made it into the top ten in the world
for the first time I saw African country
has ever made it into the top ten the
big question of course in south africa i
was just there a few weeks ago actually
in southern africa and the question now
is how is the anc going to go forward
are they going to be they're going to
take advantage of this rich legacy this
inheritance of this great first-world
developed country in africa and and and
promote the policies the rule of law the
investment regimes that the trust in the
constitution or are they going to go the
way of you know as a bob way that's
that's really the big question but
there's tremendous potential and the
people want to work that people want to
be entrepreneurial they just need a
chance thank you very much for recent TV
I am Matt Welch